How do you keep your pets safe from the summer
sun?
We've got a handful of helpful tips - and
cute pictures to go along with them.
It's win-win!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and it is
officially summer now, which means barbecues,
beaches, and yes - that dreaded summer heat.
Most of us already know how to protect ourselves,
but what about our helpless little furry friends?
They need protection just as much as we do
- so here are some tips to help your pet beat
the heat.
First order of business - Never ever EVER
leave your pets in a parked car.
Ever.
On an 85 degree day, even with the windows
cracked - the temperature inside of a car
will reach 102 degrees F within 10 minutes.
After 30 minutes, 120 degrees F. That kind
of heat can cause irreversible organ damage,
or death.
So don't risk it.
You may also be inclined to think humidity
will keep your pet cool - when in fact, the
opposite is true!
Animals pant in order to evaporate moisture
from their lungs, which cools them down.
But if the humidity is too high, they can't
do that - so their body temperature will skyrocket
- quickly.
Limit their exercise, and watch out for sunburns.
Believe it or not, animals are just as vulnerable
to UV rays as humans are.
And that is especially true for pets with
white fur, since the lack of skin pigmentation
makes them extremely sensitive to the sun.
The shorter their hair is, the more susceptible
they are to being burned.
So places on their body with the least amount
of fur - like around the face, or the underbelly,
are where they're most likely to get sunburned.
Some pets also have pre-existing conditions
that can increase their skin sensitivity.
So things like parasitic infections, autoimmune
disorders, or congenital hairlessness - should
all be taken into account.
Hairless pets are of course the most sensitive
- so if you have one, and you know they're
gonna be out all day - try using either a
waterproof sunscreen with an SPF of at least
30, or a sunblock that contains zinc oxide.
You could also try pet clothing, like a t-shirt
or a hat, which in addition to being adorable
- will also block some of the sun's rays.
Although dark-colored clothing will get very
hot, so keep that in mind.
Also important to remember - that the ground
gets extremely hot in the summer.
So if YOU wouldn't go walking around barefoot
on the concrete, then your pet probably shouldn't
either.
Keep em on the grass, and make sure they have
a shady place to lie down.
Doghouses actually get hotter inside with
the sun, so it's better to find a tree or
some place with airflow - and of course, make
sure they have plenty of water.
The sun is at its hottest between 11a-2p,
so the best thing you can do is minimize their
outdoor activity during those times.
Fans don't work as well on pets as they do
on humans either - so really, it's better
to just keep them inside.
If there's a chance your pet may ALREADY be
sunburned, check its skin.
If it's red, warm, or flaking - take them
out of the sun immediately, and apply a cool
compress with ointments.
If it's a severe sunburn, then you may need
to take your pet to the doctor.
A vet can prescribe a cortisone product to
prevent inflammation, but in extreme cases
- antibiotics may be necessary to prevent
infection.
Like anything else, an ounce of prevention
is worth a pound of cure.
So it's best to just prevent these situations
before they happen.
Frequent sunburns can give your pets pre-cancerous
conditions or even skin tumors, and once that
happens - the affected skin will have to be
surgically removed.
Don't let it come to that.
You wanna protect your pets, with the same
dedication you'd give yourself.
As always, if you have questions, comments,
or other suggestions on how to keep your pets
cool, leave em in the comments below.
Otherwise, thanks for watching - and happy
summer!